هيني احنا النهارده في حفله من دبراي ما
نتور اول حاجه عايزه اعرف ليه
غرايين
بالاسم ده فعجبني الاسم جدا واصحابي اصلا
شايفني رمادي اللي انا شعري ابيض من 15
سنه فلقيت ان ال ال
بدون الجراي بيتكون من الوان ثانيه كثير
جدا غير الاسود الابيض
اصلا انا نفسي الناس تسمعها وتشوفها
والناس ما تحطنيش في قالب معين
[موسيقى]
في لبنان ومشينا
اوجع على تملك حمود ولا عمرنا شكينا
[موسيقى]
الحفلات على الاغاني ستينجل اللي هي يعني
مش اكتر حاجه مشهوره لك ما حستش ان ده رزق
ان انا ابقى وسط الجمهور وهم بيحبوا حاجات
ثانيه مشهوره اكثر ليا ممكن ما يبقوش
حافظين كل السنجلز بتاعتي اللي بتخلي اي
فنان
لما بكون بغني دلوقتي في حفله كامله وحد
من الجمهور او اثنين او ثلاثه بيطلبوا
اغنيه معينه هم عارفينها لي مع وسط البلد
لازم افهمه
البلد انا عمري ما هاغني الاغاني بتاعه
وسط البلد بره البلد
واللي انتم فيه اكيد اي حد عدى به حتى لو
ما بيقولش اتاكد ان هو عدى بس انت شايفه
دلوقت بعد ما عدا
يعني انا كنت الناس بتقول هو وسيله سهله
لما بيلاقوش حد بيتكلم عنهم وسيله سهله
لما الناس بتيجي تنصحهم بنفس النص النصائح
اللي اصلا بتحسسهم ان هم ضعفه ومش قادرين
يتحركوا النتيجه تقولي له يا عم كبر دماغك
دي حاجه بسيطه كله هيعدي لا هو مش كله
هيعدي ولا حاجه هو وقت حزن ووقت وجع لازم
ياخذ وقته لغايه الاخر
في ناس كثير جدا وصفتها بان هي دي الحاله
اللي الرجاله بتخبيها دائما علينا او دي
الافكار اللي دائما الرجاله بيفكروا فيها
في الوقت ده في ازمه منتصف العمر دي لاما
همم
رب الاسره يعني او الاب بيلاقي ناس تعرف
تهندله في الوقت ده
ويستوعبه
لاما بيلاقي ناس مش فاهمينه اصلا وده اللي
ممكن يخليه ساعات يعمل اللي عمله هشام
بس انا كان مين دي المهم بالنسبه لي اللي
عامل علشانه المسلسل انوصل ان الطلاق ما
لوش علاقه بالاطفال